alright one of the other things I wanted
to talk about is like I'm a huge Big
Brother fan and so they just had this
season 21 a Big Brother and the other
night they had the season finale and the
season's finale was ruined because there
was allegations of racism against the
guy that won but like right before he's
about to win they come up with these
allegations and listen the guy is not he
was kind of a [ __ ] throughout the
season Mickey whatever his name is
Jackson you know he was kind of a
[ __ ] but to me it was just part of
Big Brother to me it was all games so
like in the first few episodes of the
season okay if anybody if you don't know
Big Brother okay Big Brother is a is a
social experiment people live in a house
it's taped 24 hours a day and the whole
point of it is there's competitions that
the people compete against each other in
a scheme and connive against each other
to vote each other out until there's one
person left and that one person gets
$500,000 I just want you to understand
the motivation behind Big Brother is to
win five hundred thousand dollars this
ain't a [ __ ] popularity contest
this ain't some sort of like oh let's
see who's the best character no this is
people lying scheming being people that
they're not not you know just being them
actually the most awful version of
themselves often times they're not to
win $500,000 okay let's just put that
out there all right so they had this
thing called BB camp out okay
they had a camp director all right so
like they had to it was like all these
people just got into the house and then
they all had to nominate a camp director
and then that camp director gets to pick
four people that are gonna get kicked
out of the house basically right so he
raises his hand and he's for other
people raised their hand
one of them's cliff who was the oldest
guy on the cast like really old for Big
Brother in my opinion but we'll get to
that then it was like a black dude and
isn't always not a lot of black people
on Big Brother it's a black dude this
fat Latino girl she's fat okay I'm just
gonna you know she's a big girl Jessica
a big girl
her and it just happened to be like it
happened to be like the some of the
minorities in the group raised their
hand to to be nominated for this
position the white guy won
so in he's saying it to the camera his
logic is okay what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna put up two people who also raised
their hand because they seem like a
threat if they're willing to be this
then he you know they're they're not
necessarily gonna be allies for him so
they're strong people let me get them
out cut cut to ninety nine days later
and they're and then people are claiming
that that was a read it solely based off
race and age and I just the guy was a
[ __ ] but I got no sense of racism
from him watching the season now I
didn't watch the feeds cuz you can watch
the 24-hour feat if you're a real junkie
you could watch the 24-hour fees and I
didn't [ __ ] watch the 24-hour fees
because that's like too much you know
and they even have a show called Big
Brother after dark so you could be
watching that and but I love the show I
think it's a horrible train wreck social
experiment that accentuates the worst
attributes of people's personalities for
money for them to win five hundred
thousand and for us to look at home
would be like wow these people are awful
here's what's wrong with Big Brother
right now okay
first of all they this this push towards
diversity let's make it diverse and so
for them diversity doesn't just mean
race they want to do diverse in age and
size big brother is a like more than
half of the competitions are physical
competitions like endurance competitions
and running around and jumping on [ __ ]
and if they had this old guy who to his
credit he lasted all the way to the
Final Four
but I watched the whole season it to me
cliff got more lucky than anything else
they were just bigger targets and they
had this fat girl who every single
physical competition
she failed okay she failed and they even
made the show itself made fun of her she
was like this like hold on to some [ __ ]
competition she had to hold on and they
they cut to her and she's like I just
want to prove to
you hear the voice over I just want to
prove to everybody the girls my size and
then she falls they did that on the
[ __ ] show okay here's one I don't
have any I'm not fat shaming I'm not a
this ain't about age this is about this
particular show if you're gonna have a
fat girl on the show then you need to
alter the competitions where she has a
chance to win every single one that's
just my opinion I think that whoever the
weakest link on the show is physically
like if you like have somebody with a
wheelchair in a wheelchair on Big
Brother but then you make sure all the
competitions are strictly mental or they
are like you have to use your upper body
so it seems like this person has a
chance if not you are setting them up
for failure and that's exactly what
happened and at the same time you're
also positioning them to be victims and
that [ __ ] pisses me off
let me tell you who should be on Big
Brother it should be all pretty people
like just get hot just super hot people
with in shape physiques and then let
them battle it out and we at home watch
these pretty people be awful okay
because that's what the [ __ ] is show is
it's people being awful alright they lie
to each other they scheme they make
promises that they break they break
their word it's just you know they make
these alliances and any break them they
get into these romances that you know
people fight against each other
when you combine pretty in shape people
a tie personality model looking women
and these you know you know straight you
big big tough straight guys and even
like the gay dudes who go in there who
are like super athletic if you're gonna
have these people in there and then
you're gonna combine them with like
unathletic you know fat out of shape
people and I'm like even talking about
even with personality if you're gonna
bring these people who are like like
they've been bullied outside you know
they're not the prettiest person you're
setting those people up to be victims
and I just think that
it's ridiculous okay you watch TV to
escape Big Brother it's like when you
watch love island when you watch in love
island or some dating show and it's like
all about pretty people having sex
that's why we're watching I don't need
that [ __ ] diversified with people who
look like me okay you know [ __ ]
don't want to see me on love Island with
some pretty chick in a you know in a
bikini not on TV you don't want to see
that cuz you can be like what does that
do doing you know it just sets it up for
bad vibes and that's what Big Brother is
doing in their attempt to appease all
the the social justice warrior [ __ ] out
there who are like we need to diversify
everything no not everything this show
like this going to Co hoof Nicole who
finished third she didn't do much all
season they wanna claim that I was her
game to Lilian or the radar but she's
one of these types it's like you know
she's not a outgoing person you know
she's not ugly by any means but you know
she's not like you know the the soccer
star chick who has this beautiful body
so she's already gonna be set up as like
the underdog they they put her in the
house you're the underdog and let's see
if she can get all the way but the
problem is they set this whole thing up
of like okay they had like they were
having a meeting use they're having an
alliance meeting and somebody wants to
trust to come in and they're like hey
we're having a meeting and then they
turn that into bullying they made that
into bullying no no you know what if it
was a hot person trying to come into the
room that the Alliance wasn't with they
would have just said done the exact same
thing but because you set up the
victimhood because you set up where like
here's our victims our people you know
the the underdogs of society the fat the
old the Nerds let's put them in with all
these pretty people then you instantly
create this thing where the people at
home are like I want that person to win
take that element out just make Big
Brother what it is awful pretty people
trying to win $500,000 period or if
you're gonna diversify it completely
diversify it and dumb down the
competitions let's make let's make them
competitions like like the old guy cliff
he won this one competition where he had
to hold a board you know and like like
balance a ball I was like perfect
competition cuz it didn't have to do
with him running a marathon or holding
on to anything cuz every single one of
those competition the fat girl and the
old guy they fell first
every time the final competition was you
had to like there's like you had to like
go across some swings that are held up
by rope cat chick Jessica wasn't gonna
be able to do that that would have been
a [ __ ] disaster this she had to jump
over some stuff like why set people like
that up for failure you know and then
then you're gonna make it look like oh
we made this competition so the straight
white athletic male he's gonna be the
one that's gonna win this that's how big
brother is so when you add people like
that in your attempt to diversify [ __ ]
all you're doing is setting them up for
failure and making everybody hate the
8hi personalities which were supposed to
hate them anyway because it's Big
Brother they're doing all this [ __ ] for
money so now there's this whole thing
and I thought the finale was ruined
right before they're about to announce
who wins they go oh by the way dude
there's allegations that you were being
racist ninety nine days ago the dude was
blown away
it was so inappropriate so inappropriate
and then you know he won and he just had
this stoic look on his face like wow
y'all just called me a racist in front
of America and my family and by the way
the people that called him there were
the [ __ ] that got kicked off
early cuz y'all suck at big brother
that's why you got kicked off you're not
good at it and by the way let me say
this not being good at big brother is
not an insult
it's a compliment cuz this like this
girl Kimmy who's a beautiful black girl
she sucks at big brother okay I'm sorry
you suck at big brother and I'm glad you
suck at big brother because you didn't
want to lie and scheme and act a certain
way that's what it takes to make it all
the way in that stupid show so to have
this dumbass show this stupid horrible
social experiment and then you
- like then you want to so you want to
have a stupid stupid social experiment
where people where it accentuates the
worst attributes of people's personality
and then you want to blame them for it
and then you want to criticize them for
what it does it was so [ __ ] stupid
but that's the culture we live in right
now alright that's my big brother rant
let's go to the singer mic on a 50
episode
[Laughter]